[Music]
I've dealt with guys like Trump my whole
life so of you guys who have wor PID
their own taxes they owe because they
figure as he said last time out it's
because he's
smart he's able to play the system well
I'm sick and tired of smart
guys we have great confidence in our son
he is the smartest man I
know hello I'm Dave Ruben and this is
the Ruben report it's December 11th 2023
we're live streaming on Rumble YouTube
and locals if you have not subscribed on
rumble or locals what are you doing
people rumble.com Ruben report I hope
you're watching there right now and if
you want to join us for a postgame as
always Ruben report.
locals.com uh we had the big Ruben
report holiday party here on Saturday
night and I have to say uh I was a bit
banged up yesterday but I am back in
Action right now I am hydrated and ready
to roll and uh let's just dive right
into it I want to do something a bit
philosophical on the show today because
we're seeing our institutions collapse
we're going to talk a little bit more
about that Harvard MIT upen
Congressional hearing from last week uh
and some of the other things that are
happening culturally at the moment but I
actually see a bit of a white pill I see
some some winds coming our way and I
want to jump off today uh with a clip
that's about a year old but it was
making the rounds yesterday on Twitter
there is an act R her name is Bella
Thorne you may not know of bellthorn it
doesn't really matter who she is I'm not
making this specifically about her but
she is an actress she's done some kids
stuff over the years she was on a Disney
show am I right she was on a a Disney
show and what's better than a Disney
program for the young people uh but she
was on Bill Mars podcast about a year
ago uh there was a trans joke being made
by Bill and her reaction and I think
it's indicative of sort of the snowflake
generation that we've been talking about
for for years now that somehow over the
last couple days we've gone from
generation snowflake trigger warnings uh
all of that nonsense microaggressions
and now it's like oh but you know
calling for genocide of people is okay
but these things these are not
coincidental they are deeply connected
because of that intersectional period uh
pyramid that uh you all know about so
today we will have an exploration into
how the woke have perpetuated anti-white
and anti-jew hatred Across America and
how it is totally baked into the system
right now except maybe a new system is
being born that is the plan let's see if
we can accomplish it first off a video
from Bill Mar's Club random podcast this
is actress Bella Thorne uh having a bit
of a meltdown over a joke by Mr Mah
there's a lot of transends you know I
always see that in the paper about
somebody who is switch their sex which
I'm all if that's what makes you that
what blows your dress up is all
the way hey yes bad fat
why bad bad bad
be who you are yes claps right claps
makes me happy I mean I think there's
some uh money to be made in some sort of
exchange with everyone switching where
like you know if you need a penis take a
penis if you have a penis give a penis
you know like if people are becoming
like men to women they're going to cut
off their penis and then there are women
trans iing her going to need a penis uh
I feel like if there was some exchange
uh maybe Bitcoin could be involved and
you could you
know no I just don't like joking about
oh Bella I know that you like to but I
see this is where the oh for fake what a
shame that is where you're that is you
don't have to be sorry but I'm not
and that is where your anxiety comes
from there is nothing wrong with joking
nothing wrong about that it's not
everybody is that sensitive not
everybody needs to be that sensitive
even the people who are doing that I
don't think would need to be offended by
that everybody is so easily offended you
kids you wake up offended all right so
first off I want to make it clear I'm
not offended by any of this and I'm not
outraged by any of this nor nor showing
it to you so that you get outraged right
I'm not trying to play into the system
system here uh but it's going to set us
up for where we're going today now the
the joke in it of itself is actually
kind of funny right like there's this
set of people that want to chop off
their genitals and there's another set
of people that want to chop off their
genitals and they want to swap those
genitals it's kind of funny right like
there's something there you may not have
laughed out loud but there's something
there uh also there is something
actually kind of funny of sort of like
what the end of liberalism would be
would be two Hollywood celebrities drunk
in stone talking about chopping off
genitals right like there's something
there she also says something that I
think is kind of interesting just like
be who you are just as if well if you
wanted to be who you are you'd be like
well look at that uh that's what I am
right so it's not be who you are what
she's saying is oh you have some thought
in your head let's have you know
surgeries pump ourselves full with drugs
and everything else but but I want to
show you one little piece uh further
from this because then so she's not
happy with the joke right and again
we've been told
jokes are dangerous and all this stuff
but it continued where it got a little
more emotional for Bella I don't know if
you're really offended or you're just
worried that you're going to look
offended no I'm 100% offended like when
when I think about you know someone's
trama and someone W the videos that I
have seen that are so like so bad and
what people have to worry about walking
on the street just being themselves like
anxiety that's why I don't like to like
joke about it because you know someone
hears it and on a public platform is so
bad because you're like kind of lowkey
spreading like this like oh and it's
like it's not funny okay again I am not
may I never mention Bella whatever her
name's name is on the show again this is
not to destroy her or anything else I'm
just trying to show you a little pin
that that what she represents there this
this thing about being upset over jokes
and how everyone is so fragile and
microaggressions and Trigger warnings
and all these things and she's seen
videos of people afraid to walk down the
street like what I like really where
where we we get a lot of hoax uh you
know hate crimes things like that but
like there are trans people I suppose or
people men dressed up as women or women
dressed up as men that are walking down
the street right now maybe even in your
neighborhood if you live in a blue City
most likely but they're walking down the
street and they're not getting attacked
we get the numbers on the amount of
trans people that were attacked on the
street for being trans yesterday that's
going to be a deep dive he's going to
work on that but this thing she's very
emotional about it and it goes to
show how fragile and I would say at some
level almost almost clinically I don't
know that I can give I can fully say
clinically I'm not a clinician but
clinically insane the woke left has
become overc comedy because it is a
subject they have created a certain set
of subjects and a certain set of people
you cannot joke about and then when
something actually has an opportunity to
to when you have an opportunity to say
something truth and make say something
true and make a joke about that they are
completely incapable and I'm going to
prove that by showing a clip of sat
Night Live from this past Saturday and
if you laugh I can't have you watching
this show anymore but before we do that
let me talk to you guys about Patriot
Supply you can't handle the truth the
truth is the clowns running this joint
live for chaos many of our problems
could be solved overnight but they let
them be destruction fuels them if you
can handle that truth you need to visit
my website prepare withth ruben.com
you'll get $60 off a much-needed
four-week emergency food kit for my
Patriot Supply the country's largest
preparedness company my Patriot Supply
is your Fighting Chance at survival
sealed inside a rugged package these
delicious meals last up to 25 years and
provide over 2,000 calories a day eat
right in emergencies with this 4-week
food kit for my Patriot Supply at the
low price you can get one for everyone
in your family visit prepare withth
ruben.com order by 3 p.m. for free same
day shipping prepare with ruben.com
prepare withth ruben.com before total
chaos ensues uhoh and now back to me
okay so I set you up there with a a
video that's making the rounds right now
but I'm telling you it's not it's not
something you got to get your panties
all wrapped up in if you're a dude
wearing panties right now you shouldn't
get all freaked out about that it was to
it was to illustrate this thing that has
happened throughout society when you
want wonder why kids are so confused
about everything whether it's gender or
whether it's supporting terrorist
organizations it's like that thing that
Bella emoted there that's a thing that
has been culturally pushed into children
so now I want to show you a clip from
sarin live sarite live used to be a
funny program a long long time ago it is
not anymore comedy the whole point of
Comedy is to say something true and make
you laugh because then you start
thinking right and the beauty of Comedy
is that if we are all in on the joke
together if we can all make fun of each
other and be part of that thing then
that's the healing process right but it
has to be true and wokeness has killed
comedy because wokeness is an ideology
and when you push ideology into comedy
you will get everything wrong so now you
remember the Congressional hearing last
week uh when representative Elise
stefanic was uh I would say I was going
to say railing those three chicks but
that was a different hearing sorry uh
when she was uh nailing well that also
could work in that context look she was
talking to a bunch of college profess uh
College presidents and asking them are
their universities allowing for the
cause of genocide at their universities
and do is that congruent with their
bullying and harassment policies right
that's separate from the First Amendment
schools have a pamphlet you get to a
school they say these are the rules of
the school those are often separate than
free speech in terms of the government
and the First Amendment anyway here is
Saturday Night Live trying to make fun
of that hearing and I can tell you I'm
just going to lead you they got this
completely backwards
go thank you chairwoman now I'm going to
start screaming questions at these women
like I'm Billy ikner anti-Semitism yay
or n I'm sorry what yes or no is calling
for the genocide of Jews against the
code of conduct for Harvard well it
depends on the context
what that can't be your answer you pen
lady same question yes or no well we are
serious about stopping all forms of
hatred anti-Semitism
islamophobia the second one and my te
lady chance to steal and keep in mind if
you don't say yes you're going to make
me look good which is really really hard
to do so I'll ask you straight up do you
think genocide is bad could I submit MIT
an answer in writing at a later
date am I winning this
hearing somebody pinch me miss stonic
your time is up oh thank God the chair
the chair recognizes gentleman from
Michigan thank you I yield my time back
to miss
stonic damn it I am here today because
hate speech has no place on college
campuses hate speech belongs in Congress
on Elon musk's Twitter ate private
dinners with my donors and in public
speeches by my work husband Donald Trump
man they are they are truly the death of
Comedy I don't know how many writers SNL
has they probably have 30 I would say
somewhere it's probably between 30 and
50 writers on top of those comedians or
actors whatever they are um everything
they did there was the reverse of Truth
it was the reverse of what we all saw at
that hearing um did Elise stefanic
scream questions like that well we've
actually got video of Alise stefanic
asking those very questions to those
very ladies you might remember this but
let's kind of clean this up for you does
calling for the genocide of Jews violate
pens rules or code of conduct yes or
no if the speech turns into conduct it
can be harassment yes I am asking
specifically calling for the genocide of
Jews does that constitute bullying or
harassment if it is directed and severe
or pervasive it is harassment so the
answer is yes it is a context dependent
decision congresswoman it's a context
dependent decision that's your testimony
today calling for the genocide of Jews
is depending upon the context that is
not bullying or harassment this is the
easiest question to answer yes Miss Mill
so is your testimony that you will not
answer yes if it uh is if the speech
becomes if the speech becomes conduct it
can be harassment yes conduct meaning
committing the act of
genocide the speech is not harassment
this is unacceptable Miss Migel I'm
going to give you one more opportunity
for the world to see your answer does
calling for the genocide of Jews violate
pens code of conduct when it comes to
bullying and harassment yes or
no it can be harassment the answer is
yes there there's just so much there
that no matter how many times I watch it
it's just incredible I mean this idea
that if it becomes action in essence yes
so oh if you've committed the genocide
we might have a problem with our
bullying and harassment code of conduct
we'll have to look into that the way
she's smiling the entire time which they
didn't do on SNL uh of course SNL also
made it seem like Alise stonic was
totally hysterical and making it about
her and screaming and acting childish as
you see none of that was true so they
kill truth with bad comedy good comedy
actually uh instills truth bad comedy
actually destroys it but the reason I'm
showing you this is because I want you
to see the woke the left whatever you
want to call them at this point they
inverted moral compass trans jokes are
bad jokes about black people or Latino
people are bad but if if you can make
fun of those pesky Jews or white people
you're going to be promoted and given
money and given jobs and everything else
just for context try to think if there
had been a bunch of kids walk white kids
let's do white Christian kids those are
the worst right walking through the
Harvard campus or upen or MIT walking
through the Harvard campus calling for
the genocide of trans people or calling
for the genocide of black people do you
think there would be some strange
equivocation with these ladies but the
point of all of this to bring it back to
where we started is that when you see
this actress Bella Thorne and her Hollow
it's thin it's nothing her sympathy her
fake virtue signaling for others uh it's
it's a completely consistent with their
backwards moral compass right so then
when people actually come out and
they're like yeah kill kill half the
world's Jews and sure they're on our
campus over here but those people's
feelings don't matter it makes perfect
sense when you understand what that high
that crazy oppression pyramid looks
looks like so now let's jump over to the
view I'm giving you a warning can we
warn the people I got a warning there's
some sort of Y there you go it's a
certifiably crazy person noted racist
who gets everything wrong and as she
admitted last week no one in her family
likes her Sonny host uh
defending the three College presidents
as they say over there in Israel believe
they can I can I just wait
here because um you know I think this
this what uh Alise toonic the
congresswoman was talking about and what
this entire hearing was about should
have been about free speech and free
speech and although many people may feel
uncomfortable with it the most hateful
and heinous speech is the most protected
speech okay campuses have not been good
for free speech in years well so but but
they have been actually has
wor what you heard was them saying what
is completely accurate under the law it
depends on the context so if someone
does yell at a crowd racial slurs or
calls for genocide in a public place in
a crowd that is protected speech one
onone confrontation if a white student
for example says to a black student a
racial slur then it's
the codes of talking about the law but
the codes of conduct must adhere to the
law so when it's law to protect students
no it it really can't go against the
Constitution of the United States so
when we're talking about this one-on-one
type of thing yes that is when that
conduct leads to harassment and could be
actionable by the university and that's
exactly what har as it said you have to
commit genocide to be able to condemn
genocidal language like that's a that's
a dangerous
I cannot believe it I cannot believe it
I am going to defend what's her name
what is her name Alissa Farah yeah she
was right and she also pointed out I
cannot believe it I cannot believe it
it's a Christmas miracle Not only was
she right there about do you have to
actually commit the genocide then have a
problem as she points out this was about
the school's code of conduct Sunny host
who I'm told is a lawyer who should have
she should have her head examined and
whatever law school get gave her a
degree probably should look into how she
got that degree in the first place she's
making the argument about the First
Amendment the first amendment has
nothing to do with the school's code of
conduct when you go to a school or you
go to a place of work they hand you a
pamphlet or someone in HR department
emails you something and they have
certain things that they expect you to
abide by what's our one rule in this uh
operation over here in the Ruben report
Studio no short I don't want to see
anyone's legs while I'm trying to do a
program that's the one rule here you
want to make fun of trans people you
want to call out for the genocide of
Jews in this room we're going to be
pretty uh liberal with that sort of
thing but I just don't want to see your
legs while you're doing
it so this has nothing to do with the
First Amendment so every single thing
that Sunny said there was a lie also
this odd distinction between if you
harass one if you say to one black kid
i' I'd like for the genocide of all
black people and of course she uses the
example of the white person saying it
right because she doesn't want to do
exactly what's going on here and be like
generally a bunch of either Arrow or
black or something or saying some stuff
about the Jews or just broken
purple-haired you know white trans
weirdos something like that so she makes
it about the white kid going after one
black kid but it's not about one-on-one
you can't say it's to three black people
I'm going to kill you or you got it you
got it but this is the nonsense that
passes by the way I want to give credit
to the blonde on The View that nobody
knows too right nobody knows her name it
doesn't matter but she says college
campuses haven't been good on Free
Speech which that's really what this is
all about they've flipped their whole
narrative on Free Speech overnight so
that they can go after Jews and buy
extension white people right so for
years we've all known they've been
horrible on Free Speech the second now
so she says they haven't been good on
free speech and sunny has the gall to
say yes they have brain damage truly
truly brain damage if you know someone
and it's most likely your mother or your
aunt who is watching The View you've got
to take them and take them to a forest
or a distant Place probably in Utah they
have deprogramming camps you put them
out there in a forest and they have to
figure out for a few months and
they will come back and they will not
watch The View anymore but why is the
woke whether it's Bella what's her name
or sunny host why is their moral compass
so inverted well there is a reason for
it they have injected race into
everything so even though most of us
especially if you're of a certain age
you just don't care I don't care what
anyone's skin color is I judge people on
the content of their character there
used to be some guy who said that that
people used to like but theyve injected
it into everything culturally so again
that's why now we have a generation of
kids that have everything backwards you
know who also used to inject race into
everything the Nazis that was a thing
that they did and we were always told
they were the bad guys but soon enough
they'll be the good guys for these
backwards weirdos so now I want to show
you another uh clip that from a show
that I cannot believe is still on
television I don't even know who the
host is at this point but The Daily Show
uh which was very popular for a long
time it's still on apparently I guess
they're rotating in and out uh guest
hosts watch how they they bring on this
comedian Eric Andre and I guess he's
black he he looks kind of black he's
black he's black all right I'm told he's
black I don't really care for these uh
things uh watch how the host tries to
get him to talk about race and how
oppressed he is and he just not into it
I mean what do you have to be worried
about in America as
someone uh that
is uh so devish
handsome like I don't know who that
woman is or but like what you bring on a
comedian how about do something funny no
tell me how oppressed you are guy who's
most likely a multi-millionaire who's on
television gets to say whatever he wants
has a bunch of cash and is a celebrity
tell me about your oppression how do you
walk down the street like those trans
people who can't walk down the street
but they have Associated color and your
genitals
with group identity and then they have
decided how successful you can be in
society related to that so now I want to
show you a trailer and again I'm not
showing you these things so you're
outraged by these people or you try to
cancel them or anything else what I'm
trying to show you is that this thing
that we are now all fighting that has
been exploded everywhere and this would
be a good moment to welcome all my I
would say new audience members who maybe
were more Lefty a couple months ago but
have kind of come around on this and we
we see a whole bunch of new people join
us which is absolutely great so I got to
lay out the the road map here for how
did we get here well we got here through
all of our institutions cultural
institutions and entertainment
institutions and academic institutions
pushing this nonsense that would lead us
to this place as I said before where you
know being anti-jew ah little genocide
is cool and of course you can go after
white people and everything else so now
I want to show you this trailer for a
new George Lopez Christmas movie and uh
as you watch this trailer try to imagine
if they had reversed the races on this
one enjoy I have a surprise for you Mom
Dad this is my boyfriend your boyfriend
OAS in your Sanchez puppy did not family
meeting in the Mexican home right
now what are you doing here I would like
to ask for your daughter's hand in
marriage Mr sanchz from the director of
From Prada
toada that no I wanted a Brown
Christmas not a white Christmas I wanted
a traditional
Christmas he wants a Brown Christmas not
a white christm now look again I am not
outraged by this I get
it except that if you reverse that now
show me the comedy show me the Christmas
time comedy produced out of Hollywood
where a white family brings in the
Latino and then they're like the
father's like I want a white Christmas
and the whole thing is how they're going
to push him out of now I'm sure at the
end it's all going to work out and all
but that's not the point it would it
would be it would be a horror movie if
it was reversed right but they have made
everything about skin color nobody cares
about this everyone in our own families
you have people married people have
different skin colors sometimes of
different religions different thoughts
different all of that stuff but the
system will not let us let have us let
go of ancient hatreds and prejudices
because the more it injects it into the
system the more can control us because
we're all walking around in a world that
is not connected to our reality because
most people actually are pretty decent
someone who's not decent is Robin
D'Angelo Robin D'Angelo is I guess you
could say the mother assuming she's a
woman I think she has a vagina but who
the hell am I to say uh who is like the
mother of the sort of white women who
hate themselves enough to constantly bow
at the altar of racism she has written
white fragility and a bunch of this
other nonsense and of course uh it is
constantly being pushed into all of your
children's programs uh here is a robin
D'Angelo book White fragility being
pushed into a Disney children's
show well you understand love don't you
no no I do not understand anything about
white fragility white fragility what's
that supposed to mean you know what it
means you're doing it right now doing
what being defensive about race Robin
D'Angelo wrote a whole whole book about
it read it page 39 same um page cover
and
everything my dad wouldn't even look at
the diary he said this people would
never own slaves how could he just
dismiss me like that white fragility oh
brother quame the white guy was being
nice he was being perfectly fine I think
it was at his house and he has this guy
over like it's evil and it's
injected everywhere what was the guy's
name it was leboit something so they
also try wanted to make him be half Jew
did you see that it was Liu's Carill or
something it it's so pervasive and evil
what these people are doing and again
Disney has been at the center of so much
of this we we showed you this video a
couple months ago but but it's worth
noting again because it's not just the
programming it then gets infected in all
of the stars and then your children put
posters up of these people and
everything else so Disney's new Snow
White Star her name is Rachel zler here
she is criticizing the original Disney
movie as
predatory I mean you know the the
original cartoon came out in 1937 and
very evidently so um there is a big
focus on her love story um with a guy
who literally stalks her yeah weird
weird so we didn't do that this no not
weird and even if you think it's weird
stop destroying art then Disney people I
get it she's just the irrelevant actress
she's just a footnote in history and
doesn't really know what she's talking
about but then how about instead of
trying to destroy Snow White a story
that everyone uh remembers that everyone
watched when they were a kid and nobody
thought it was about predatory behavior
or or anything evil how about you guys
create new things but Disney can't
create new things because wokeness is
the end of creativity it's why it
destroys comedy it's why they destroyed
Star Wars it's why they can't do
anything with the Marvel movies anymore
and everything is just repetitive driil
because they
canot create uh there is a guy who can
create and he's doing an awful lot he's
sending us uh to Mars and Rockets he's
creating electric cars he's buying
Twitter so that he can save free speech
and a whole bunch more and of course I'm
talking about Elon Musk Elon was on uh
it's called the Monroe live podcast over
the last couple of days and he was asked
about what's going on with with Disney
and how uh Walt Disney would feel about
the current Disney product I told
everybody I won't go into this and I'm
not going to get all you know emotional
and everything but to me I've watched
that one clip that people have been
putting out to me and putting up
against um forgotten their name Disney
land or whatever at the end of the day I
will never take my grandchildren ever to
that place ever well you have to you
have to wonder what would Walt Disney
think of the company that is his
namesake today I'm telling you what I
mean I think Walt Disney's turning in
his grave faster than the drill bit I I
can turning in his grave faster than the
drill bit yeah he's got to be right look
there were some things to talk about
Walt Disney that weren't so great but
Walt Disney created something that
became over decades our our biggest
entertainment institution the movie
making the TV shows the parks capturing
all of our dreams and then something
happened and we can all discuss when it
exactly happened probably somewhere in
the 80s it started changing a little bit
ramped up a bit in the 90s until it
burst forth where we're at right now
where Disney is literally putting on
things for children that are telling
them they are racist by the color of
their skin um they have too much power
by the way there is a guy who fought
Disney and won his name's Rona santz
he's running for president you might
want to look in to him because there's
an orange man trying to stop him but I
think he's probably a better candidate
but that's not here that's neither here
nor there right now but it's not just
that Elon has been on the front line
against these woke corporations uh but
he also is on the front line when it
comes to free speech so now over the
weekend this has got a lot of people's
also panties in a bunch again I don't
want to uh say who might be wearing
panties related to their sex but Alex
Jones you guys know Alex Jones from
Infowars uh has been suspended by all
the big Tech things and everything
everything else but he's still here cuz
usually censoring people doesn't stop
them well he is officially back on
Twitter here is a tweet from Elon he did
it by uh popular vote reinstate Alex
Jones on this platform and 70% of
basically 2
million people said yes now for just the
purposes of today's show I'm actually
not going to take a position on Alex
Jones I I have no problem with him being
back on the platform at all uh but in
terms of his politics or things done or
Sandy Hook or anything else let's just
forget that for a moment if you the
reason I mentioned this is because if if
you think of all of the things we've
talked about today all of the things
happening in the country right now do
you think that Alex Jones is really the
problem here or is there some other
problem well another guy who is kind of
becoming problematic for the system is
Tucker Carlson and Tucker Carlson as you
know has a new show on X Twitter and he
brought Alex Jones on over the weekend
to talk about this neoism and what is
happening in our society to race-based
systems because that is a very effective
system but why did people put up with
that I mean like if they were doing that
to Malaysians or Filipinos or Hondurans
I would say you can't do that you're not
allowed to attack people on the basis of
their race I'm sorry not in a country
like this because a country will fall
apart and it's immoral I totally agree
but nobody says anything I don't get it
the reason they've done it is most of
the enforcers of this are white liberal
women 45 or older not fair it's just a
fact and their their cucked husbands and
so to them can I just say that the
phrase cucked husbands is the best it
really is true so if you get around
these white liberals they live in the
whitest areas they're totally scared of
anybody with brown skin but they virtu
signal constantly and then say yes the
white people are are bad you know the
white people are are evil uh and you
know these these I mean I've even seen
white people sit up there and say yeah
it's time to deal with with these
crackers and they're a white person
saying that so from Jackson okay so
there's some interesting stuff there the
phrase cucked which some of you don't
know basically do I have to Define this
on a daytime show it's basically like a
guy and it's generally like sort of a
liberal guy who tends to be married to
this white liberal woman who lets other
guys bang his wife in front of him like
that's but but that that's like the
literal meaning of it but it's more like
oh you just have no authority over
yourself or your marriage or your family
anymore and what has happened largely is
that these these white liberal women now
I'm not going to play the identity
politics game but let's say these these
leftist people who largely are women
women have been more Bamboozled by this
stuff uh they are married to these guys
and the thing is and this was I think I
came up with this theory about six
months ago this is what I call the
Theory guys like getting
every now and again all guys of
all stripes and all Walk of Life it's a
thing everybody in the room n nodded
right there everybody we've got a
special guest and everybody was like yes
we
do now if your wife is a crazy leftist
lunatic and you're like you know that
Donald Trump is not totally a Nazi or I
don't know maybe I don't want to get
injected with that stuff but she's a
leftist lunatic and you have to debate
that every night at dinner at some point
you kind of become a cuck because you
might want a and again is it
fair to say everyone everybody wants a
okay so that is kind of that's
basically what Alex Jones and Tucker
Carlson are saying the deeper point that
Tucker is talking about there really
though of course is that this anti-white
thing and which again it's it's just
connected to the anti-jew thing now
right because Jews are just Primo whites
according to this idiotic uh this
idiotic movement whatever you want to
call it the bigger idea is that if this
was about anybody else he's right if
this was about nicaraguans if this was
was about Vietnamese or any we would all
know it's evil with this thing we have
allowed it into the system and now we
have to start purging it from the system
and again I said at the beginning of the
show we got some white pill stuff so
we're about to get there uh I want to
show you an interview that James Lindsay
you guys have seen James on this show
many many times uh he and Jordan
Peterson sat down and they talked about
how this left-wing
authoritarianism is actually connected
to malignant narcissism so when you see
these women who want trans kids who want
to bow at the altar and pretend they
love black people so much and they are
wrong that it's actually something
deeply within them that leads to the
worst of the political ideas before I
got what would you say disenfranchised
from the University my lab did a study
on left-wing authoritarianism the first
thing we did was to see if there was a
clump of ideas that were statistically
related that you could describe as both
leftwing and authoritarian and and there
is and inside identifiable it's exactly
the clump of beliefs you would have been
studying and would suspect yeah we
looked at what predicted that predicted
Allegiance with that set of beliefs low
verbal intelligence negative .4 with IQ
verbal IQ so you think well how can
people be you know unwise enough to F to
believe these ideas and one of the
answer is well they're not that bright
as it turns out being female having a
feminine temperament right those were
the three big predictors other
predictors have emerged looking at the
similar construct leftwing
authoritarianism the best predictor I've
seen is malignant narcissism correlation
is
6 6 right which is about as good as the
measurement accuracy of the
questionnaires yeah right so it it it it
actually opens up the question the
question is there may be no difference
between left-wing authoritarianism and
malignant narcissism and what that means
is the serpents are using the language
of compassion to mask their power
striving well simultaneously claiming
well of course we can do this because
every single social relationship in the
world is predicated on nothing but power
and if you don't accept that that just
means that you're a malignant liar
that's right exactly that's the whole
structure yeah yeah yeah that's right
that's the whole structure so the three
indicators that would lead to this
malignant narcissism that then lead you
to this seriously sick set of political
views as Jordan laid out female okay
female and men are female and male men
and women are just wired differently
right like this is that's not racist
that's not that's not sexist or anything
else it's true men generally generally
there of course there's always outliers
men are more into things and girls are
more into people that's women are more
into people that's how it works right
that's that's just how it works so the
the three factors he said female he said
not that bright right and they've done
this they've done IQ checks now try to
picture the purple haired lunatics that
are out on the streets these girls with
purple hair do they seem particularly
bright are they taking particularly good
care of themselves and everything else
and then female temperament so that's
the other one now that one's the most
interesting one cuz he didn't because he
already said female but female
temperament and this leads you to the to
the cucked male the male who puts sort
of thoughtfulness above everything else
and when thoughtfulness is above
everything else when tolerance is above
everything else which has a little more
to do with the female temperament you
will welcome all of the lunatics into
your house to rape and pillage right as
Douglas Mari says The Barbarians will be
at the gate and we will be debating what
gender pronouns to call them so
malignant narcissism leads one to
left-wing authoritarianism and these
things are interchangeable so now go
back to where we started today Bella
Thorne there's a malignant narcissist
there but speaking of malignant
narcissist it's not just chicks I want
to be fair remember Anthony fouchy a man
who should absolutely be in jail but
instead is making 400 Grand a year for
the rest of his life on your uh on the
government payroll uh well he did
another interview I mean the guy should
be hiding in a c and never be seen again
he should be so embarrassed by what he
has done or Andor in jail maybe they
could turn the cave into a jail whatever
uh here he is being interviewed talking
about his faith as a Catholic but don't
worry guys and remember malignant
narcissism is the theme here he has
figured out a personal ethic so that he
doesn't have to believe in anything else
other than his personal ethic there's
dog in Chapel with Chris that's when you
married right yeah yeah yeah it's
beautiful yeah it's really really nice
do you still go there do you you don't
practice anymore do you I don't
why uh a number of complicated reasons
go on we have a whole
Corridor first of all I I think my own
personal ethics on life are I think
enough to keep me going on the right
path and I think that the there are
enough negative aspects about the
organizational Church mhm uh that you
were very well aware of I I'm not
against it I identify myself as a
Catholic I was raised I was baptized I
was confirmed I was married in the
church my children were baptized in the
church but as far as practicing it it
seems almost like a proformer thing that
I don't really need to do guys Anthony
fouchy who locked you in your house who
forced you to be injected with an
experimental medication who funded the
very research at the Wuhan lab that let
this thing out who kept kids out of
schools basically destroyed the known
world for three plus years in the
ramifications of that likely for decades
to come we just have no idea um he has a
personal ethic that uh works for him and
he doesn't need the church now I'm not
telling anyone that they need the church
I'm not telling anyone they need uh the
temple or anything else but do you think
there might be a connection between
someone who could be so malignantly
malignantly narcissistic as Anthony
fouchy that would then lead him to be
the tyrannical Maniac that he he became
and perhaps maybe I don't know maybe the
guard rails that religion and belief
provide um actually stop someone from
going off the deep end and doing the
horrible things that he's done I think
it's possible uh and all of that of
course leads us to you because it is up
to you to figure out how to live and how
to make sure that these people will not
have autonomy over you you will have to
make choices for yourself because they
are not going to stop whether it is
covid or the Alien Invasion or the
threat of nuclear war or whatever
they're planning uh so now I want to
jump to an interview over the weekend
with tennis champion novic jokovic who
is now the most acclaimed tennis player
of all time you may remember he couldn't
get to a couple Grand Slams during covid
because he would not get vaxxed and uh I
think he's turned out to be quite right
about all that and uh listen to him
about Freedom correct me if I'm wrong
you were not against vaccination you
just did not want it for yourself
exactly people try to you know declare
me as an antiva I'm not antix nor I'm
Pro prox I'm I'm I'm Pro freedom to
choose yeah this is a guy who now has
more tennis Awards major Grand Slam wins
than anybody he skipped the US uh open
he was not allowed in the United States
because he didn't get the back so he
could have even more aades than he has
but he he's a tennis player right like I
don't think this is someone that 15
years ago would have been like I'm I
will be on the Forefront of fighting for
freedom and medical autonomy right he
was like I like to play tennis but we
find people out of all walks of life
that then become sort of avatars for the
way we should all be living so there is
an alternative to the malignant
narcissist of Anthony fouchy it's
someone who's pro- Liberty Pro morality
Pro responsibility doesn't want to own
you doesn't want to endlessly grow the
state so you just become a cog and a
machine that does not care about you and
that brings us to what's going on in
Argentina because you know a couple
weeks ago Argentina got a new president
Javier Malay and he was inaugurated over
the weekend and this is going to be in
Spanish with some subtitles so I'll
translate it afterwards but it's rather
[Music]
beautiful
Long Live Freedom damn it Long Live
Freedom damn it Long Live Freedom damn
it yeah freedom is good freedom is the
answer and what's happening in Argentina
right now and man I I I don't know what
layer uh the system is going to use to
try to take him out or or make it so
that Argentina won't work but he is out
there doing the right things for his
people in a country that the government
had grown and they had destroyed the
value
of everyone there who is trying to work
and make something for themselves
because the government because
government growth equals personal
responsibility destruction so the vision
is the Malay Vision it's a winning
vision and we have to instill this in
our institutions because if we do that
then we can crush the ever growing
government and you may I think we've
shown this one twice but it's worth it
it's just beautiful this was Javier
malle's first plan of action which he is
now putting into place he has already
cut uh he had there were 21 government
departments he's already cut them down
to nine but this was him laying out
exactly what he was going to
do
a lot of Spanish there for those
listening on the audio podcast but the
end was the thievery of politics is over
and he's just ripping off the titles of
these departments and he's saying no
more we will not fund them anymore we
will not take money from our citizens
for these ridiculous things like gender
in sports programs etc etc so if you see
Malay and you see Argentina as as a
little Beacon of Hope right now well now
because I told you we were white pilling
you guess what that that vile creature
from University of Penn who smiled
through that entire hearing
uh she is no longer the president of pen
uh here's an email that was sent out
from University of Pennsylvania a
message to the Penn Community dear
members of the pen Community I write to
share that President McGill has
voluntarily tendered her resignation as
president of the University of
Pennsylvania she will remain a tenured
faculty member at pen carry law on
behalf of the entire Penn Community I
want to thank president McGill for her
service to the university as president
and wish her well so she is out and
there's a little postcript to all of
this which is breaking I think just in
the last couple hours but you guys know
Chris Chris rufo who I've had on the
show many times who has been one of the
the real thought leaders in how do we
take out wokeism how do we get it out of
our institutions he has now
found old documents from president gay
which I can't believe her name is
President gay but president gay over at
Harvard and it sounds like uh she was
stealing a lot of stuff for her her
foundational docum that made her
president in the first place so we will
find out if gay is going to survive so
the point of all of this guys is we are
capable of winning this if we have
energy if we if we have truth on our
side Argentina can do it and America can
do it and all you have to do is speak up
and call these frauds out that is our
show for this
Monday it was it was a lot of drinking
on Saturday and then and then I'm
hydrated from yesterday I lost it there
I lost it there guys I want to show you
my meme Monday over at Ruben report.
locals.com in 1950 they said we'll have
flying cars in the future 2000 we were
still waiting on flying cars 2023 peanut
butter and jelly sandwiches are they
racist find out after the commercial
break uh postgame show coming up in a
few minutes Ruben report. locals.com
people of the internet live at one
o'clock oh and my full interview with
Brett Weinstein is up across platforms
right now it's a really interesting dive
into a lot of the things that we
discussed today and I leave you this
might be our most disturbing cold
closing of all time we're going back to
the view for this one and and we
couldn't figure out a way to really get
this one into the theme of today's show
it involves joy bayar and an orgasm so
if you want to mute this thing now we'll
see you on the other side adios to me if
he's happy with you and you're having a
good time why are you bitching but also
so whoopy it's really not the quantity
it's the quality of the four but she
doesn't know what the quality is one of
if if just one out of the four could
locate my G-spot I'm all in I
[Music]
don't